First, peel off the skin Squirrel Kigawa will take off his clothes if there is a cut.
You can make it the sister Ah
Sherpa What do you mean by eating it raw? Are you complaining about the way we eat?  So I'm going to use the tap that I made in Tashiro
Once you do it, there will be no difficult parts to eat, and
you can enjoy it without waste
Who taught you about Hashiripa-san's knowledge of hunting?
If I was taken around,
I also prefer the mountains to knitting at home
.  And surely, surely,
1. Take a moment.
I
used all my teeth and bones to make the broth, and the salty taste seeped out from under my chin, and
it arrived.
It's crunchy and
has a nice texture
Everyone,
what is that
Words that express gratitude
I'm also at the meal